well we're at it again on a monday
edition of p-f-t-o-t p-f-t-p-m because
there has already been some surprising
news this one was tipped off by peter
king in football morning in america
receiver deandre hopkins thought to be
available in trade chris i had heard
last year that one of the sticking
points between bill o'brien the coach of
the texans and brian gaine the former gm
was that o'brien wanted to trade hopkins
and gaines position was like the rest of
us are you crazy well now with gain not
there hopkins on his way to arizona and
the texans picking up david johnson the
texans also giving up a second round
pick wait the cardinals give up the
second round pick the two teams flip
flop fourth round picks your reaction to
the texans pulling the plug on one of
the best receivers in football
well i you know i've heard you say you
know that before about the the things
you had heard last year uh i heard the
rumors out there that people thought
deandre hopkins might be
on the trading block i i i really did
not think it was going to happen
i really did not now i do think it's
kind of a win-win as far as x's and o's
are considered for each team i do i mean
the texans have a huge need at the
running back position david johnson
really fills two roles in one because he
is a phenomenal pass catching back which
makes him a first and second down
between the tackles type runner but then
also can do the things we've seen out of
new england running backs for years
right because billy o'brien that's the
offense he runs dion lewis james white
whatever david johnson is like a slot
receiver when it comes to the pass game
so i'm sure they looked at it like that
uh now the the cardinals yeah they need
a go-to target for for kylie murray and
if they want to build around kylo ren
they need a guy that's a proven
commodity right now hopkins in the prime
of his career and yeah both teams needed
this certainly the texans seem like
they're taking on a little bit more risk
than the arizona cardinals because david
johnson has not played a lot of football
the last two years and that's a little
concerning at the running back position
you just have to wonder
about the extent to which deandre
hopkins history with bill o'brien may
have been a factor here right remember
before he got paid about a year before
he got paid there was an incident where
he showed up for training camp and then
was going to leave and it was like too
late you've already reported the rules
change when you've already reported and
then he came back after a short holdout
finally got his contract there was the
ugliness in 2017 after the late bob
mcnair made his statement about the
inmates running the asylum hopkins quit
practice that day you just wonder
whether or not bill o'brien has carried
around this you know what he's more
trouble than he's worth attitude on
deandre hopkins right or wrong but you
don't trade away a cornerstone player
like deandre hopkins unless you have a
reason for it and you're taking on the
full contract i'm told the texans are
paying the full freight on david johnson
that's 10 million dollars that was fully
guaranteed this year that helps out the
cardinals they were stuck with david
johnson they couldn't cut him because
the money was already guaranteed for
this year well even better they trade
the contract plus a second round pick
and a flip of fourth rounders to get one
of the best receivers in football to
pair with kyler murray it's a steal if
you're the arizona cardinals and it
makes people wonder what the hell bill
o'brien is thinking chris
well yeah i get that i understand that
you know and you know the things you're
saying about bill o'brien deandre
hopkins you know as we know in this
league you know usually where there's
smoke there's fire i don't know any
having any inside info there i think the
other thing we got to take into account
here you know just from the texans
perspective and you're right i mean tick
for attack right now yeah you could
argue deandre hopkins was the best
player and i mean the best receiver in
football last year i mean you could make
a case i would definitely argue he was
second best maybe behind just michael
thomas right now i think the other thing
though that we gotta look at just as far
as football is concerned one now risky
as this may be the texans do have kenny
stills and they have will fuller now
both have had a little bit of injury
issues themselves here the last two
years but they're pretty talented in
that you know as far as receivers are
concerned i think the other thing that
maybe we need to think about a little
bit
deandre hopkins has a year like he did
last year
uh he's going to ask for 18 to 20 he's
gonna ask for 22 million dollars a year
and i think probably the texans
probably saw this coming i wonder if
they've already had those type of
conversations with his agent to know
that's the type of demand that's going
to happen going forward and maybe that's
why they realize hey that's going to be
too rich in the future let's get
something from now and move on i don't
know that i'm just throwing that out
there that's the way i would be thinking
uh if i was a gm or running the texas
you know and that's a good point because
we got three years left on the deal 12.5
million this year 13.5 million next year
and 13.9 million the following year
and he may be looking at julio jones
saying what the hell he's at 22 yeah i
want more now and maybe the cardinals
are going to have to sign on and commit
to that and you look at it from from two
different perspectives the texans are at
the point where they have to pay desean
watson soon so they're not going to be
in a position to give deandre hopkins
huge money the cardinals still have at
least two more years before you even
open the door for a potential extension
with kyler murray now's the time to load
up a bunch of money into the pockets of
deandre hopkins if that's what you want
to do so i think it makes sense that way
but chris here's the thing remember
remember the colts game i remember
talking to
darius leonard
after one of the colts games uh where
they lost
and i i remember they they uh
i'm trying to remember exactly what
happened i mean basically i knew the
ball was going to the andre hopkins
because he's all they got right he's all
they have so who do they throw to now
i know and no i i remember you're
talking about that first game their
first meeting of the season in
indianapolis uh where you know i believe
the texans had a fourth down late in the
game and they don't deandre hopkins over
the middle right and yes
yes and to your point you're spot on he
has been the go-to crutch for deshawn
watson almost a bad thing at times for
desean boston i think you've heard me
complain about it over the last two
years there's times where i just go damn
all he'll look at is deandre hopkins he
won't get off him it could be three guys
on deandre hopkins and deshawn watson
will still be there pat in the ball
looking at him
now
but but to your point you're right mike
there's no proven go-to
consistent commodity at the wide
receiver position for the houston texans
and that's a little scary scary i mean
you know how many times this year did we
talk about like is wilford playing is he
not playing
that that alone
made the difference of whether you or me
pick the texans to win football games in
a lot of weeks so i that is a very
concerning real point there uh but i
guess they look at it and go hey will
fuller they he's a you know a first
round pick or he was certainly a high
pick i can't remember he's the first or
second stills they traded away from he
was a first rounder he was right and
david johnson was you know he's a guy
that's he's multi-purpose running back
slash receiver and i think this contract
situation with deandre hopkins because
he's grossly underpaid i mean you said
it 12 and 13 million dollars a year for
what he's producing on the field right
now i wouldn't be shocked if he was
clamoring for bigger money right now as
we talk and that's maybe what got the
texans thinking about dealing deandre
hopkins and kind of moving on from him
yeah i i i think you're right and i i
think that that the history with hopkins
and the very real possibility that he
was going to want to get paid a ton of
money at a time when they have plenty of
other needs and they also need to be
paying desean watson that got them to
move on and o'brien has to have a
strategy he has to have a plan for a new
number one receiver
you can't trust will fuller to stay
healthy and kenny stills isn't the
number one guy
they got to find somebody else and
whether that is picking up amari cooper
um but but here's the thing you got to
pay cooper and you don't even know
cooper you knew hopkins this one's going
to be tough to sell to the fans in
houston there's going to be a lot of
upset texans fans about hopkins leave
and i've already seen kenny stills
tweeted a gif of uh of a guy you know
kind of like what the hell is going on
here and i think fans are going to feel
the same way so you know bill o'brien
the head coach and bill o'brien the gm
had better rely on amy palczyk the pr
executive to sell this thing in a way
that that unruffles feathers because
people are going to be very upset about
this move
yeah i i would agree i mean come on we
know deandre hopkins i love the guy
personally i mean i i really do i love
watching him play i was a guy that
didn't give him enough credit early on
in his career and and uh you know really
he is a go-to
superstar type wide receiver not the
kind of guy that's gonna you know catch
slant routes and go 80 yards for
touchdowns but man he's got some of the
greatest hands i've ever seen in the
history of football he's one of the best
in traffic people around them hanging on
them uh wide receivers i've ever seen
and i would think there is going to be
some backlash mike but within this i
think hey they got a second round pick
maybe they you know dally with a second
round receiver as we know is a very deep
wide receiver class and maybe bill
o'brien is thinking you know a little
bit new england patriots where he's
thinking maybe more wide receiver by
committee this year and he's going to
look for you know some value type
signings and free agency at the wide
receiver position where you know he
might not have to break the bank to get
some of these guys but they feel like
but he feels like they're a good fit for
his football team
and you get what you pay for
right that's the reality if you don't
want to pay the best receiver in
football then you're not going to have
the best receiver in football and you're
going to have to make do with whoever
you have
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports